[Musique]
oh le saviez-vous les gars moi j'aime
faire la
je me suis trouvé de Nana et
c'est bien meilleur à
[Musique]
drois
moiard en roi de la
forêt de Fontainebleau jusqu'au Congo
belge moi j'aime bien prendre mon pied
même la forêt n'est plus vierge
excusez-moi je suis en retard qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça bah c'est la forêt la
forêt quoi bah la forêt vierge pour la
forêt ça pour le côté vierge tu
repasseras à moi les
[Musique]
filles comment tu t'appelles toi Ellie
et toi comment tu t'appelles Anne vous
appellerez
Elian
[Musique]
oh tard tu es le roi des amants et quand
on lui suffffit pas il fait appel à
[Musique]
chita Taron est un
infomane il drague les
hippopot les filles si vous voulez du R
montez sur mon
gros est un superman
il de en l'autre jour s cassé il est
tombé
coer alors gag
leocotier qu'est-ce que c'est ça c'est
un cocotier de
Noël
[Musique]
oh le roi des
amants le
roiant à cheval sur ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
éléphant al déjà non déjà il sait pas
faire le singe mais dislui qu'à chaque
fois il fait qu' fait l'éléphant il se
trome ce mec là mais laissele tranquille
il n'a rien pour sa défense
ouis je voudrais bien vous y voir
moiir on est allé au fond de la jungle
dans une tribu de pigmet
VO qu'est-ce que tu fais là toi bah je
fais la tribu de pigmet dehors je vous
avais dit que j'étais trop grande moi je
vous l'avais
dit nous on enlevé toutes nos
Fring Fring mais bien qu'est-ce que tu
fais encore toi là je vais la
jungle elle est pas mal elle est pas
mal on ne manque pas d'astuces on fait
l'amour dans les cactuses et encore plus
difficile dans la gueule d'un crocodile
ou
[Musique]
ohant tu es le roi des amants et quand
on lui suffit pas il m son
ca c'est quoi ça ça c'est un caillement
qui a mangé une
chèvre c'est pas possible tuas jamais
mangé du fromages caill ah bon moi non
plus
[Musique]
d'ailleurs bon les enfants c'est pas que
ça mais RRE à la maison qui m'attend
allez on va faire la
[Musique]
Bangou